an emergency alert service is being
launched to warn people about
potentially life-threatening events such
as wild fires and severe flooding the
government is to test the system next
month meaning people will receive a
siren-like message on their phone live
to our correspondent Alice Porter who's
in The Newsroom so here we are here's my
phone what am I going to get on this
trusty device well either on your phone
or your tablet if there is an emergency
the government wants to alert you about
it your phone will vibrate it will read
a message out to you and there will be a
siren that will go for about 10 seconds
I think we can hear a little bit of what
that will sound like
so this is the alert that will only be
sent by the emergency services or
government bodies which are dealing with
an emergency and not only be sent when
there is an immediate risk to people's
lives that includes things like severe
flooding fires extreme weather and
public health emergencies
it's also hoped that almost 90 percent
of mobile phones in a defined area could
be reached under the new plans now this
system has been tested in in local parts
of the country but it's also hoped that
on the 23rd of April everybody in the
country will receive one of these alerts
and the idea is that by having everyone
in the country receive it they also have
to acknowledge it as well and that will
be they won't be able to continue using
their phone unless they acknowledge it
and that's going to be on the 23rd of
April and it's not going to cause any
privacy concerns briefly because the
fact that the company is in a way some
might say is looking at how the phones
aren't operating well the cabinet office
have been Keen to stress that they are
not keeping anyone's personal data and I
think it's important to stress that this
people's personal data isn't being used
you're not having a text message sent to
your own personal mobile what it is is
that if you're in the vicinity of an
emergency they know that because of data
that's being gathered from cell towers
and that's how it's working but I think
the moment from the government's
perspective they've looked at other
countries the U.S Canada that have got a
similar scheme being that's been rolled
out there they're really hoping that it
could be instrumental particularly in
cases of extreme weather such as
flooding the fires we saw last summer as
well but it also has an enormous amount
of potential if there is a terrorist
attack they've not said they're going to
be rolling out for that but they are
going to be looking at the potential but
also people cannot out out of this they
don't have to continue with it but the
government is very much hoping that
people will continue with it and saying
it could save lives